(chants religieux)
l'Achigan répondent présents.
THÉRÈSE AMIREAULT, mbmbre
Fabrique Paroisse Bienhe l l l é
de St-Roch a senti le besoin
de s'unir.
- L'équipe paroissiale a
rapidement organisé popopopopope
de l'épreuve que traverse
cette communauté tissée serrée.
CLAUDE RICHIE, curé parosese
Bienheureuse Marie-Rose Durocher
- Pour passer au trave
des difficultés, des épreuves,
on a besoin de cetrérérésence,
on a besoin de l'amour
des autres.papapapapapapapapapa,
les véhicules de la Sureté
du Québeususus rappellent
que tout n'est pas encore
élucidé au sujet de la
défl j j j j j j j j j j j j j ,
le périmètre de sécurité est
ououours érigé et l'enquête
pourrait prendre une autre
tournure. Radio-Canada a apprisu
négligence criminelle.
Des travaux étaient en cours
lorsque l'explosion est survenue
chez Propane Lafortune e d d d .
MARCEL SAVARD, ancien directeur
général adjoint Sûreté du Québes
minutieuse sur les lieux pour
essayer de voir où et quoi et
dans quel état est-il au momentt
fonctionnait-t-il au préalable,
au moment des opérations.
SÉBASTIEN MARCIL, maireococococn
- Depuis jeudi, dans notre
famille, il manque du monde.
- Les élus, également ébranlés t
que les policiers iront au f
de l'affaire.
- On laisse vraiment la Sdududus
fouilles et ses recherch
Je comprends bien que la scène
est relativement com
LOUIS-CHARLES THOUIN,
député, CAQ, Rousseau
- Prenons le temps de faire
les vérifications nécessaires,
je pense que c'est i
LUC THÉRIAULT, député,
Bloc québécoislmlmlmlmlm
- Qu'ils ouvrent la possibilité
d'une enquête pour négligence
criminellentntntntntntntntntntne
et de regarder toutes
les facel'l'l'l'l'événement.
- Les responsables
de l'entreprise n'ont pas voulu
commt t t t t t t t t t t t t ts
des deux employés et du sous-
q q q q qui manquent toujours
à l'appel.
Ici Carla Oliveira,
Radio-Can
St-Roch-de-l'Achiga